[Music]
we have guests matter with it uh chicken
bits are falling off edge it what the
hell good Gloucester he's a complete
knuckle hand I'm awfully sorry about
that but um you see he thinks it's still
the 1918 or 1914 some right there isn't
it I'm his late onset of um well robot
dementia
I don't it's all pretty well I don't
know what you're smoking in that pipe
man what's going on here would you drag
me to some transformer retirement home
look somebody but I start talking I'm
out of here
whoa okay um bumblebee we only met when
I was a little boy in short pants that
must mean that's all maybe taller or
maybe short I can't remember but your
face fee you know this guy oh yeah let's
have a look at this thing
he's very interesting yes you keep a
secret for so long
knowing it to be true and yet deep down
inside you begin to wonder has my life
been wasted have you ever felt like that
mr. Cain
it's just Kade look old Tara I don't
have a ton of patience for riddles right
now yes but you want to know don't you
dude why they keep coming here to earth
right
ah I do so love perfect timing
no no anything why do you have to be
like oh so is this a kidnapping sort of
situation on her first transformer
experience was both really she's very
difficult
it started as a legend one of the
greatest of all thousand years who've
kept it hidden to protect Earth from
what was destined to arrive Optimus
Prime you destroyed your home you seek
Redemption
I
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard stay away
from any boy in a band especially a
drummer
these are troubled times without leaders
chaos reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way now the
greatest mission of them all to turn the
tight of human history
[Applause]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
[Music]
a few brave souls
[Music]
save everything we've ever known the
operation is over when I keep it up my
prime okay
and I once I sit
you
for my world to live
yours must die
[Music]
[Music]
you